hey guys i'm off the grid for august and  uh well here's aoc and if you want to  know why i go off the grid it's because  of [ __ ] like this  people think congress and government is  all about leading people but ultimately  a lot of our politics is about following  the public will and the people who  change what people think are artists and  drag queens and let's not forget who  threw that first break at stonewall  you know that is what led to us passing  the equality act and the house in this  term marriage equality it starts with  you i mean your patriots  you are  you are you are patriots and i'm so  proud of you all i'm so proud to live in  this country with you and with your  mother  and  with all of us as family